Women!
You can’t live with ‘em, can’t live
without ‘em.
Or can you?
Hello firestorm of sexism happening down in
the comments section, I’m Jules here for
DNews.
Making a baby is… pretty straightforward.
At a base biological level, it simply comes
down to a sperm cell fertilizing an egg cell,
also called an “oocyte”, which undergoes
cell division, develops into an embryo, which
itself develops into a lil baby.
How that happens, whether it’s in-vitro,
or artificial insemination, or just plain
ol’ “doin’ it”, is kind of beside
the point as far as nature is involved.
At least, since 1827, that’s what we always
thought.
See, before 1827, scientists thought that
humans came pretty exclusively from semen,
which they believed was the origin of a teeny-tiny
human, also called a “homunculus”, which
just grew into a bigger one inside the womb.
But in 1827, Karl Ernst Ritter von Baer, Edler
von Huthorn, which a single person’s name,
became the first to actually observe the egg,
called the “mammalian ovum”.
Since that time, we haven’t found anything
else we can mix with sperm to make a baby.
In 2004 there was a brief attempt at tricking
egg cells into thinking they had been fertilized,
which caused them to start dividing and turn
into zygotes.
But as expected, you just can’t make a whole
mammal without both halves of the equation,
that is, chromosomes, and the fake-fertilized
eggs died after a few days of development.
And so, that was it.
That is, until September 13th, 2016, when
Scientists at Bath University in the UK published
a study, wherein, using mice, they were able
to fertilize a type of embryo called a haploid
parthenogenote, which is NOT an oocyte.
Many publications described it as being closer
to “skin cells”, as unlike an oocyte,
it had already undergone cell division.
That’s kind of a huge deal because it kind
of implies that we really only need the “sperm”
part of the equation, which brings us right
back to the ol’ “homunculus” theory
of development.
The idea that the female egg is interchangeable
seems kind of crazy.
And… that’s because it is.
See, what nearly all of these publications
are neglecting to mention is that the haploid
parthenogenote which the scientists managed
to fertilize is derived directly from… a
female unfertilized egg.
In fact, it’s the egg in the exact same
stage of development that I mentioned earlier,
where scientists tricked it into dividing.
So, really, scientists fertilized cells that
had just stopped being an egg.
Now, that’s not to say that what these scientists
discovered wasn’t groundbreaking; it absolutely
was.
The fact that an egg that has been tricked
into starting development can be fertilized
afterwards means that whatever reprogramming
of the sperm that is going on to allow embryonic
development can happen outside of the singular
egg cell.
While that doesn’t mean we can make a baby
out of some sperm and a toenail, it does uncover
something brand new about embryonic development.
So, it sounds like we still need
women to make babies
Unless we can figure out some
way to get a man pregnant.
Or have we already?
Stay tuned and find out in a video coming out later today!
Also, if you’re a fan of 360 and VR videos,
Seeker has launched our brand new Seeker VR
channel perfect for watching your favorite
videos using the YouTube app or VR device.
So put on your headphones and get ready to
experience videos in a whole new way!
So why do we even have sex in the first place?
I know it seems obvious but watch this video with Trace
for a little more unique explaination.
So what do you think? Do you think we'll ever
be able to make a baby without both halves
of the equation? Let us know down below in the comments
and don't forget to like and  subscribe for more DNews everyday of the week.